Вітаю вас, друзі.
Мене звуть Юрій, я викладач математики
«Креативної Міжнародної Дитячої Школи».
Сьогодні у нас урок математики в 6 класі.
В 7 класі вас чекає розділення математики
на два окремі предмети
– алгебра та геометрія.
Геометрія – це наука, яка
вивчає геометричні фігури.
В 6 та 5 класі вас поступово готують
до цієї науки, до цього розділення.
Сьогодні ми розглянемо
деякі основи геометрії,
а саме: паралельні та
перпендикулярні прямі.
Для початку давайте згадаємо
такі нюанси, як кути та види кутів.
Кути бувають гострі та
прямі. Кути позначаються АВС.
Обов’язково в середині повинна
бути, так звана, вершина кута.
Зазвичай кути позначаються
за годинниковою стрілкою.
Ще раз, кут АВС – це фігура,
яка складена з двох променів,
променя ВС та променя ВА.
Гострий кут – це кут, який
знаходиться в межах від 0 до 90 градусів.
Прямий кут, на дошці
зображено, це кут KLM.
Прямим кутом називається кут,
у якого градусна міра 90 градусів.
Перейдемо далі.
Наступні види кутів, так звані, тупі.
Кут АВС зараз тупий,
градусна міра його знаходиться
в межах від 90 градусів до 180.
Розгорнутий кут – це кут,
градусна міра якого є 180 градусів.
Перейдемо далі.
Також давайте згадаємо деякі нюанси,
які пов’язані з прямими,
точками та відрізками.
Зараз на малюнку зображена пряма МК,
для позначення прямої
достатньо двох точок цієї прямої.
Пряма, вона є нескінченною,
в неї нема ні початку, ні кінця.
Або ж пряму позначають за допомогою
маленької букви латинського алфавіту -
маленька буква а.
Відрізок АВ, позначається лише дві точки,
це частина прямої обмежена двома точками.
Також для сьогоднішньої теми
потрібно згадати належність точки
до відрізка або прямої.
Увага на дошку.
На моєму малюнку є відрізок
АВ та дві точки, точка N та точка Р.
Точка N належить відрізку АВ.
Записується це таким чином: N належить АВ.
Ось цей значок «Є» - належить.
Точка Р не лежить на відрізку АВ,
тобто точка Р не належить
відрізку АВ і записується це так,
Р перекреслена буква Є відрізок АВ.
Давайте з’ясуємо, що ж
таке перпендикулярні прямі?
Перпендикулярні прямі – це прямі,
які при перетині утворюють прямий кут,
тобто кут, градусна
міра якого 90 градусів.
Спершу буде досить
важко вимовляти це слово,
перпендикулярні – це прямі, які
утворюють при перетині прямий кут.
Подивіться уважно на дошку.
Зараз пряма АВ та пряма
MN перетинаються між собою
і утворюють кут 90 градусів.
Скажу який кут, кут ВОN, він прямий.
Очевидно також, що утворюються
ще три кути по 90 градусів.
Це кут АОN, кут АОМ та кут МОВ.
Всі вони прямі і дорівнюють 90 градусів.
Перпендикулярні прямі позначаються
спеціальним символом, подивіться уважно.
MN перпендикулярно АВ.
Оцей символ, такої перевернутої «Т», є
символом перпендикулярності двох прямих.
Якщо прямі позначаються
двома маленькими буквами,
пряма а та пряма b позначаються так само.
Пряма а перпендикулярна прямій b.
Ви бачите, що зараз вони утворюють
разом між собою кут 90 градусів.
Всі чотири кути по 90 градусів.
Треба розуміти деякий нюанс.
Відрізки АВ і KL зараз не перетинаються,
але насправді вони між собою
теж є перпендикулярними.
Я к це зрозуміти?
Запам’ятайте! Відрізки які не
перетинаються є перпендикулярними,
якщо прямі, яким вони належать
між собою перпендикулярні.
Подивіться, будь ласка, я зараз
відрізок АВ продовжив до прямої і побачив,
що він перетинається з
відрізком KL під прямим кутом.
Ви подивитесь на дошку і скажете, що я
зробив помилку або щось не те позначив.
Я позначив перпендикулярність
таким символом.
Символ виглядає ось так.
Я зустрів в європейських книжках,
що символ перпендикулярності,
тобто прямий кут, позначається
саме таким символом.
Майте на увазі.
До цього ви постійно зустрічалися
з перпендикулярними прямими
та перпендикулярними відрізками.
Ми вивчали, так звані,
прямокутні трикутники.
Увага зараз ВС та ВА між собою
теж перпендикулярні відрізки,
які лежать на перпендикулярних прямих.
Тобто прямих які перетинаються
під прямим кутом, тобто 90 градусів.
В прямокутнику теж у нас є 4
пари перпендикулярних відрізків.
Відрізок ВС перпендикулярний відрізку ВА,
відрізок ВА перпендикулярний
відрізку АD, тощо.
Коли ви вчили таку геометричну
фігуру у просторі, як паралелепіпед,
ви теж стикалися з
перпендикулярністю двох відрізків.
Подивіться уважно на малюнок.
У цього паралелепіпеда є 12 ребер
і кожні два сусідні з них
будуть перпендикулярні.
Я позначив зараз три пари
перпендикулярних ребер між собою.
Ребро EF перпендикулярно ребру FD,
відповідно ребро KF
перпендикулярно ребру FD,
а також ребро МЕ перпендикулярне ребру EF.
Перейдемо до паралельних прямих.
Паралельні прямі – це дві прямі
на площині, які не перетинаються,
називають їх паралельні прямі.
В своєму житті ви постійно
зустрічаєтесь з паралельними прямими,
наприклад рейки трамвайних
колій або розмітка дороги.
Згадайте, де ще ви зустрічалися
з паралельними прямими?
Подивіться уважно на дошку.
У нас зараз є пряма MK та точка
N, яка не належить цій прямій.
В мене до вас питання.
Скільки я можу провести прямих через
точку N, які будуть паралельні прямій МК?
Відповідь очевидна – лише одну.
Увага на малюнок.
Лише одна пряма буде паралельна
прямій МК, яку ми провели через точку N.
Пряма а паралельна прямій МК.
Знак паралельності записується
таким чином, дві паралельні риски.
Пряма а паралельна прямій МК.
Один з найважливіших наслідків
паралельності прямих є такий.
Зараз пряма b перпендикулярна прямій МК,
тобто вони при перетині
дають кут 90 градусів.
Також пряма а перпендикулярна
тій самій прямій МК,
вони в перетині дають кут 90 градусів.
Отже, пряма а і пряма
b між собою паралельні.
Запам’ятайте це.
Це нам знадобиться для
побудови паралельних прямих.
Давайте перейдемо до розв’язування задач.
Зараз на дошці вказано квадрат
MNKB, у якого проведені дві діагоналі.
Діагональ NP і МК.
В мене питання до вас.
Скільки зараз на малюнку
зображено перпендикулярних відрізків?
Тобто, скажіть будь ласка, скільки
пар перпендикулярних відрізків тут є?
Правильна відповідь така.
Давайте рахувати разом.
Відрізок МР перпендикулярний
відрізку MN – перша пара.
Відрізок MN перпендикулярний
відрізку NK – друга пара.
Відрізок NK перпендикулярний
відрізку KР – третя пара.
Четверта пара - МР перпендикулярний до РК.
Вони перпендикулярні, бо у квадрата
сусідні сторони утворюють кут 90 градусів.
Але запам’ятайте!
У квадрата також є одна особливість.
У квадрата діагоналі його теж
перетинаються під прямим кутом.
Тобто відрізок МК і відрізок
NP теж перпендикулярні.
Отже, ми маємо 5 пар
перпендикулярних прямих.
Наступна задача. Задача цікава.
Скажіть, будь ласка,
скільки точок перетину можуть
давати три прямі на площині?
Подумайте уважно.
Давайте розглянемо всі можливі випадки.
Перший випадок очевидний, коли
ці три прямі між собою паралельні.
Перша пряма, друга пряма та третя пряма.
Будь-які двіз них не перетинаються,
отже вони дають 0 точок перетину.
Пряма а паралельна прямій
b, паралельна прямій с.
Отже, вони дають 0 точок перетину.
Давайте розглянемо інший випадок.
Наступний випадок виглядає так.
Нехай всі ці три прямі
перетинаються лише в одній точці.
Проведу одну пряму, другу
пряму довільно і третю пряму,
яка теж буде перетинатися в цій точці.
Тобто три прямі перетинаються
лише в одній точці.
Це другий випадок.
Давайте перейдемо до третього.
Третій випадок найпростіший.
Кожні дві прямі між собою
перетинаються. Давайте це зобразимо.
Нехай це перша пряма, друга
пряма перетинається з першою.
Також третя пряма перетинається і
з першою, і з другою в різних точках.
У нас утворилося три точки
перетину. Раз, два, три.
Перейдемо ще до одного випадку.
Останній випадок такий.
Нехай дві прямі будуть
паралельні між собою.
Зображу це на малюнку,
тобто вони не перетинаються.
Третя пряма буде перетинати обидві з них.
В 7 класі ви познайомитесь з цією
прямою, вона називається січна.
У нас утворилося дві точки перетину.
Отже, можливих випадків стільки.
Коли взагалі не має точок перетину,
коли всі три прямі між собою паралельні.
Коли існує лише одна точка перетину?
Коли всі три прямі
перетинаються в одній точці.
Існує момент коли дві точки
перетину, коли дві прямі паралельні,
а третя перетинає ці дві прямі.
Він зображений на дошці.
А також найпростіший випадок на мою думку,
випадок, коли у нас три точки перетину.
Коли кожні дві прямі
між собою перетинаються.
Перейдемо до останньої задачі на сьогодні.
Запишемо коротку умову до задачі.
Отже умова задачі така.
Нам дано, що прямі АВ
та СD – перпендикулярні.
Тобто перетинаються під прямим кутом.
Також дано, що кут MOC і кут
ВОК разом в сумі дають 130 градусів.
Також дано, що градусна міра
кута СОК дорівнює 42 градусам.
Питання до задачі знайти
градусну міру кута МОК.
Я позначив його хвилястою синьою лінією.
Давайте думати як це зробити.
У нас є сума двох зелених
кутів та червоний кут.
Якщо ми додамо суму двох
зелених та червоний кут,
разом ми знайдемо градусну міру
кута МОВ. Давайте це запишемо.
Перша дія.
Кут МОС додати кут ВОК і додати
кут СОК, буде дорівнювати куту МОВ.
Давайте обчислимо,
чому це буде дорівнювати.
Сума МОС та ВОК дорівнює 130
градусів. А кут СОК – 42 градуси.
Отже в сумі це разом
буде давати 172 градуси.
Давайте думати далі.
Відомо, що кут АОВ розгорнутий,
тобто його градусна міра 180 градусів.
У нас знайдений кут МОВ, це 172 градуси.
Отже ми можемо знайти градусну
міру кута АОМ. Давайте це зробимо.
Для цього потрібно від
180, тобто розгорнутого кута,
відняти градусну міру кута МОВ.
Запишемо це.
Кут АОМ – 8 градусів.
Третьою дією ми можемо
знайти градусну міру кута МОС,
який позначений однією зеленою лінією.
Нам сказано в умові задачі, що прямі
АВ і СD перпендикулярні між собою,
отже утворюють кут 90 градусів.
Кут АОС = 90 градусів.
В попередній дії ми знайшли градусну міру
кута АОМ, вона дорівнювала 8 градусів.
Давайте зараз знайдемо
градусну міру кута МОС.
Для цього треба від 90 градусів
відняти 8 градусів. Запишемо це.
Дорівнює 82 градуси, це
градусна міра кута МОС.
Щоб розв’язати задачу, ми в останній
дії додамо градусні міри кута МОС
та градусну міру відомого нам кута СОК.
Таким чином знайдемо
градусну міру кута МОК.
Давайте це проробимо.
Четверта дія.
82 градуси, тобто градусна міра кута МОС,
додаємо 42 градуси –
градусна міра кута СОК.
Буде дорівнювати 124 градуси.
Це відповідь до задачі. Кут МОК.
Задачу розв’язано.
Пропоную вам вдома самостійно
знайти за цим самим «дано»
градусну міру кута МОD. Спробуйте.
Отже, сьогодні на уроці ми з вами
познайомились з такими основами геометрії,
як паралельні та перпендикулярні прямі.
На наступних уроках ми з вами
навчимося правильно будувати паралельні
та перпендикулярні прямі за
допомогою косинця та лінійки.
Дякую за увагу. До наступних зустрічей.